Because of your accent. Yeah. I know. I want to ask a question if that's okay,
because of your accident and where you're from. Yes. Are you a Republican?
Um, nothing. I'm an independent registered independent.
Hm that's it I'm so I'm like when it comes to, uh,
money fiscally conservative, me too. Uh,
when it comes to, uh.
Yes. Pretty, pretty open to that. Pretty liberal there. Yeah. Yeah. Well,
you know, it's more libertarian, like.
Yeah, pretty much. Yeah. You're a libertarian.
Essentially. Right. But, um, I can't and w you know, we're not getting,
we don't go into politics. We don't, we.
We don't know enough. We don't, I don't know enough. We don't,
which is why I don't really talk about it.
Cause I don't like to give an educated, I mean,
I'd rather give you an educated opinion. I don't have that.
When it comes to politics,
I don't have all the facts and I don't want to get up there on the high horse
and say, well, here's how it should be. And I'm like, Oh, I got that one.
Here's why I bring it up. Yeah.
The reason why I bring it up is because there is, you know,
you look at my brother, Steve, for instance, right. My brother,
Steve thinks that if Texans right,
are all cowboy hats and Wrangler jeans and they have spurs, he doesn't.
Realize he thinks that spurs.
Yeah. He thinks that if you go to Texas, Oh no.
There's like really everyone looks it's every mass here.
Almost exactly everything.
Yes. But there are people that think that like, you know,
people with Southern accents,
thick Southern hazards are from the States that may,
maybe that they are a Trump supporter. Just,
just based on just the exit where you're from and thing.
And I just want to say that, you know, I don't care if you are or not. I'll be,
I love you, regardless, because I know how you feel about me.
I know how you feel about gay people. Right? Right.
I know how you feel about people's rights and whatnot. And there's,
there's nothing oppressive about how you feel about the world. Yeah.
Right. You're a good dude. I'm being real. You're a good guy.
I really do believe that I am one of.
The best guys. Like, like.
I agree. I agree with you about.
Me. Yeah. So where do you live now? I live in.
Hickory, North Carolina, moving back. My dad had a stroke a year ago.
So I was out here. I got here in 2000. I was here 18 years. And then,
you know, like I said, earlier, career has always done this,
had peaks and valleys and lows and highs.
And I get to the point where I actually miss my family.
I miss my mom. I miss my dad. I miss my brother. I miss everybody.
And I haven't been there in 18 years. I missed out a lot of.
So when I would go home and visit,
it would be for Christmas or Thanksgiving and holidays. And it was, you know,
it's not the same.
And LA was getting more and more crowded and more and more.
Uh, my property value went up at a, at a townhouse in studio city. So I thought,
let me put this on the market and see what happens. And it was like, bam.
I'm like, Oh, that's good. Yeah, good. It's a sign I'm out. Um, and I do,
nothing has changed for me. I still do the, uh,
I'm doing more in Hickory that I'd done out here in about five years because I
have time and people who want to help for no other reason than they like to help
me. And they were my friend, you know, um, I don't have to pull favors.
It's different, you know, out here, it's like, you know,
we all have business managers, agents,
and all this stuff and lawyers and you say, let's do this thing. Like, well,
let me check my calendar.
I don't know if I can do that because I did this thing. And it's like,
it's hard to get anything done.
They save it. Cause I was in San Antonio and um, the locals there, right.
They drive me around. They'll pick me up at, you know, mean noon,
right. To take me anywhere.
There's just a different kind of energy when it comes to
different towns like these people. And I bet you, these kids,
all these people that grew up with you, John is also, you've been on television.
That must boggled their minds and in their heads, they're like, yeah,
we don't need much. We just want to be a part of it. It's exciting. Yes. Right.
And that's cool.
Yes, yes it is. Yeah. So, um, I I'm loving it. You know,
I'm actually living in the house I grew up in right now.
Everything you're saying is going to make me all like all cried. My.
Dad is in a skilled nursing facilities, paralyzed on his left side, which is,
but it's real close to our house. And my mom, my mom doesn't, you know,
she's got glaucoma, she has brittle bone.
She doesn't really know how to do a lot of stuff. You know,
she's not computer savvy. So I'm having to wrangle all the medical bills,
all this stuff. So I went home to do that.
And I'm actually happier now than I've been in a long time. Oh my God.
And I'm so happy that I have the ability.
To do that. You know what I mean, John, I want to say this. Um,
my dad died a month ago. He had a stroke 10 years ago. Okay.
And, um, he had a major stroke, you know,
and then he kept having him and um, he struggled for 10 years.
I saw him maybe five times in that 10 years. Oh. And um,
maybe six times. And um,
and now every single moment of my life is
regret of not spending more time with
him. Yeah. And by you doing this right now, it really just it's,
it's the only I'm telling you right now, dude. It's the only move. Yeah.
Secondly, this business has changed.
It's changed to the point where you don't necessarily really have to be here
anymore. You know what I mean? I'm I'm,
I have a couple of shows that I,
I have a Netflix cartoon that they asked me to do,
and then I pitched a thing that might happen. But my point is,
is that I think I could have done that if I lived in Phoenix or Ohio and you can
do this anywhere, anywhere. Um,
but the problem is you can't get the best guests, so no, that's true.